Vegas, baby!
It's Paradise.
Not metaphorically either, this literally
isn't the city of Las Vegas -- look at a map
and you'll see the name Paradise -- and when
you visit and check the weather: same thing.
Here is Las Vegas and here is Paradise which
contains *nearly everything* people associate
with Las Vegas including the sign.
Now, you might think Paradise is just a relatively
unknown city mistaken for its larger neighbor,
like elsewhere, but Paradise isn't a city
at all: it's an unincorporated place.
What's that?
Quick government recap: citizens living in
a city have to follow the rules of the city,
and also those of the county, and also, the
state, and also the nation.
It's a government layer cake.
And each layer collects its own taxes to enforce
its own rules.
If some folk find these layers oppressive,
they can hitch their wagons and head for open
lands outside the borders of any city -- to
live like the rugged individualists they are
-- free of rules.
Well, except for those of the nation, and
also the state, and also the county -- but
moving outside a city, there's one fewer 'and
also' layer because they are in an unincorporated
place.
But if they make it nice and the population
grows, inevitably people want police and sewers
and schools and rules.
And soon, a charter is written, a mayor elected
and a city incorporated.
What makes Paradise weird is that unlike most
unincorporated places that contain mostly
blowing tumbleweeds and perhaps a yurt where
nobody wants to live, there are almost a quarter
million residents in Paradise in a space the
size of Disney World.
That density is *way* past the point you'd
expect people to incorporate a city.
And it's not like Paradiseians just couldn't
bother, Paradise is almost unique in being
*officially* unincorporated … so… why?
It started with the Mormons who first settled
these lands in the 1880s… actually no -- jump
cut to: 1950!
When we still tested out nuclear bombs in
the open, near population centers.
Nevada^† recently legalized gambling and
a casino empire grew in Vegas.
Well -- *just* outside of it to avoid city
taxes.
As for necessary services, the casinos were
rich enough to provide their own notably,
using their security forces as de facto police.
Which might not sound on the up and up, but
this was the mob running things -- and of
course they don't any more.
Actually, really, they don't, it's all run
by about two companies now.^‡
Anyway, the official City of Las Vegas in
the 1950s was on the verge of bankruptcy -- and
with profitable casinos touching its border,
the mayor was all like, 'who are you kidding?,
this is totally part of Las Vegas because
I say so, and you're going to pay Las Vegas
taxes.'
The Casinos said 'no'.
There was a dispute that only the county,
the next level of government up, could resolve.
The casinos, by the way, payed taxes to the
county direct.
So *shockingly* the county told Vegas, *no*
you can't annex this land and tax its businesses
just because you want to.
And to prevent Vegas from trying anything
funny in the future the county created the
officially, unofficially, unincorporated place
named Paradise.^§
Everything that happens within it's borders,
the actual city of Las Vegas has no control
over --here the county rules and sets lower
taxes of all sorts, which is why when new
casinos are built, it's generally in Paradise
not Las Vegas.
But if all this makes you think that the origin
of Paradise was just some kind of city-sized
tax dodge... you're right!
This episode is brought to you by Audible.com--
who has over a hundred-and-eighty-thousand
audiobooks for you to listen to.
I listen to *a lot* of audiobooks every year,
and I use Audible to do it.
And I am going to recommend to you the book
that I listened to on my most recent vacation
to Las Vegas, which was “The Graveyard Book”
by Neil Gaiman.
It’s a fictional story, so I don’t really
want to give any spoilers -- let’s just
say that Neil Gaiman is an excellent storyteller
and he has an excellent narrating voice to
go along with it.
And he really lends personalities to all of
the characters that he creates, in the unique
way that only an author can.
If you are looking for a fun, enjoyable story;
this one gets my thumbs up!
Go to Audible.com/grey and you can listen
to it for free or any other audiobook that
you want for free, and get a 30-day trial.
So, go to Audible.com/grey, that’s G-R-E-Y,
to get your free audiobook -- Make it “The
Graveyard Book” perhaps and a 30-day trial.
If you’ve never gotten into the world of
audiobooks, now is the time to try it.
Now before you go around correcting everybody
that your vacation was in Paradise, not Las
Vegas, Las Vegas city and Paradise are both
in Las Vegas Valley, so you can say you went
to Las Vegas, while never setting foot in
Las Vegas, and still be technically correct
that you went to Las Vegas.